[Music]
in no spoil alertness Spenny buddy the
book is better than the movie
well they are not sometimes sometimes it
is I would say what a Harry Potter the
movies were better no I would say it
just as good cuz I only read the first
two or something like that I only saw
the first two movies and then after that
I was confused what was happening it's
just people getting blown up at magic
yeah I don't know any movies where the
movies better than the book I always
think that the book is bad because your
mind is crazy and it's longer
it's way longer the character I just
remember watching Harry Potter and
thinking like oh [ __ ] that's kind of
like how I pictured in my head as a kid
you know so that's why I love them so it
did it justice did it really yeah which
one was it that weird Dumbledore died I
can't remember people driving by at
bookstores and yelling Snape kills
Dumbledore yeah so good people melting
down that's [ __ ] up though dude it was
funny but I was you know I didn't do
that oh that would that be a troll move
that you would do though cuz it doesn't
seem like your style it's not my style
it's too easy it's too easy and I don't
think Steve trolls people's lives I
didn't make G trolls things that are
ridiculous in general that's what I hope
right you expose their stupidity you
don't ruin their [ __ ]
no I know if you deserve it you deserve
yeah yeah I don't know there's something
about the kids are you making you cry I
don't know how that makes you feel good
about yourself yeah it's like split
spoiling Star Wars or somebody in the in
the 80s or whatever yes just dick a
scientist stabbed who's calling who kept
revealing the endings of books he was
reading oh yeah yeah I don't know I kind
of think that's okay we should amend the
Constitution to add the stabbings okay
for sure for spoiling and things of
things I think it's pretty good why do
you keep doing that what was the purpose
I feel like there should be a grace
period for spoiling like if it was 10
years ago it's like that's your fault
you didn't read or watch it yeah and I
think this is just geek bullying you
know I mean like you know I think in
certain a geek nerd world like they
don't really like they're not like oh
[ __ ] give you a wedgie or whatever so
his version of bullying like I'll ruin
hi our favorite books baddie
that's true because he said he was a
scientist boiling doesn't do [ __ ]
because her [ __ ] reading you could
spoil the end for me and it wouldn't
make a damn [ __ ] difference to me
really yeah because you don't allow
yourself to get back there and invested
them no it's not that it's just more
like I could still watching it play out
has like a similar yeah what about this
you got a basketball game your beloved
sacrament okay that's fine too now
you're wanted to watch you waited for a
lot of your favorite fighter that you've
been waiting to watch for a long time
and we want to know the journey and
someone just tells you to text you right
away before you won't you go and watch
the fight I'm okay with that
like I don't ever avoid that [ __ ] like
for example right those the ahta Sonya
and Derek Brunson fight right yeah I
didn't watch it I have five pass I could
watch it later I just went yeah the
results I was like cool I'll watch the
fight later
I'm with you where I understand that
logic but it still does affect me in a
certain way yeah I think so I'm like I
like the emotional rollercoaster because
I invested my emotions so much into it
for me to figure it out and like see it
unfold before my eyes is completely
different because I'm still gonna watch
it no matter what I mean I've seen so
much shitty stuff lately wait I don't
care anymore well it depends on a genre
like you know like a murder mystery or
something where the reveal is the the
game or the real shitty like remember
the Matrix trilogy oh yeah there they
even call it that like I remember the
idea of spoiling the end of that was too
complicated for anyone to do it's like
yo so the machines and the people they
decided to have a big truce
alright repeating and it's gonna go on
forever and Neil's dead and but he's not
really dead because there's gonna be
another Neil cuz it happens over and
over and over I was just like first of
all I watched it first I don't even
watch children the first movie still
stands till it's [ __ ] good it's like
a different movie yep
and then the second movie when they go
to a desire on and ever and everyone's
like a club douchebag I was like [ __ ]
this whole city I don't care it's
because the person who actually wrote
the first one is not involved in the
other two yeah no they were both
involved the were challenged they say
that they stole it for another person oh
oh yeah you're right the original was
inspired by an anime or something like
that it was actually uh I can't remember
it was in the black lady Baroda this
lady sued them for yeah someone wrote
the story and whenever your raps or
something like that so they don't know
what the verdict was or if they settled
Alex I think it's right at all but what
happened was it was really damning for
them because the second that there was
such trash yep they're like wait if you
wrote the first one how come the second
throw it has nothing to do with the
first how come when the French guys
talking like it sounds like someone
who's trying to sound smart whereas in
the first movie like everything more if
it said it sounded smart yeah yeah
because I feel like that lady built that
whole world so she knows the backstory
but they don't write you know they just
took it that's why I haven't made
anything that's good since then probably
holy [ __ ] so this story takes place in
Antarctica what the people I just
pictured a community well of course they
stab them there's nothing bad that was
like the only thing you look forward to
what the [ __ ] and I ask did you picture
a cul-de-sac with a bunch of houses in
the cold
yeah with snow on the bone oh that's
Antarctica no before I said okay I just
had a stroke but it's okay I'm so scared
for you no I don't that's not safe I
thought I was terrified for you for a
moment
alright anyway made you think it was
cold dude no because I thought he was
going to headline the dryest deliver
I've ever heard
no cuz you said Antarctica and that's
what literally silence the room cuz he
went what no because then he's like did
you picture a cul de sac so I thought
this is before I said I see I'm tired
okay you're good anyway
and Antarctica is really warm so it was
these two scientists it's 55 year old
and 52 year old one of homes Norwegian
and the other one Swedish huh
Russian I know same thing a Russian
person someone to stab the other guy yes
he is the one that's not but I don't
know what the other guy is stereotypes
so really previously spent four years
there working together in the facility
and then so finally like you just kind
of got fed up because the 52 year old
kept spoiling the endings of the book
that the 55 year old was either reading
or was about to start eating yeah [ __ ]
removing my books get nothing else to do
all day you're looking out a window a
shoes door dice he's like sonic penis
people that's like oh you son of a book
to five-year-old he got a kitchen knife
push he plunged into the chest with 52
year-old part of his heart was wounded
and so they had to fly him out to the
nearest hospital I was about to say I
was like what do they do for emergency
care yeah yeah well they had to fight in
hospitals I was flying to Chile with a
knife in his chest and so luckily he's
gonna make it
but the guy that sagem is charged with
attempted murder well that other guy
should go to jail too though yes for the
[ __ ] book spoiler we're spoiling all
those books apologize [ __ ] listen this
is the Millennial world that we live in
I can't stand for people spoiling [ __ ] I
just think it's wrong answer should be
yes yep I mean adopted laws
oh if you're the your you know spoke
with me but I really believe this do
their 50 something years old that's
crazy
that's called irreparable harm you
cannot get that magic back of finding
the end to something I guarantee you
that dude though after he gots dead in
his heart he's probably never gonna do
that again yeah you know how like
sometimes nerds are just [ __ ] up
socially I wonder if he even knew what
he was doing was wrong like if he had
malicious intent I think he knew cuz I
think it's geek bully and I think he
knows effects that it has that is some
geek bullying unless the other guy like
once he spoiled it just kind of
internalize it and never told him that
it was [ __ ] up then maybe I'll give it
to him
a lot of these guys like they're very
they're very smart people but they don't
have smart sense of humor yeah that's
what I'm thinking they watch NBC sitcoms
and [ __ ] and things [ __ ] hilarious
yeah the door to the Big Bang Theory and
they can't stop laughing they're like oh
my god last night I almost died watch
The Big Bang Theory because I was
laughing so hard it's a really popular
show though no I know I mean but isn't
it good no but isn't that why it's
popular because it's good do you know
it's not good okay oh hey Geo I'll come
I'll come
j/k news isn't that popular it's not
that good that's true speak for yourself
that's a great [ __ ] work with dogs
for $100 a day
I know it's $100 with dogs I [ __ ] up
again I'm gonna leave early it's $100 a
day with dogs
I feel like totally different Bang
Theory does well because it's every
nerds dream to be stuck with the hot
chick well and it makes the cheapest
easiest references it's like that anyone
kind of stand it like it's like well
Green Lantern wouldn't do this you have
to know what the joke is like you can
tell he takes that seriously that's what
everyone's like I think that's all the
laughs it's like Sheldon since they make
so much money on that [ __ ] show dude
it's undo they they make somebody on the
board game bro not even don't even
mention the show yeah exactly is that
like today's friend it's been a club
yeah Oh franchise merchandise you know
about he watched it no I know about it
but I've never watched an episode my mom
likes watching it cuz she's like this
[ __ ] they say it's just so weird and I'm
like why don't think crack each other up
it's so stupid I'm like why do they need
a laugh track if it's so killer I got
the audience laugh on the row home I
can't knock it unless I watch that guy
from the Roseanne show David it was one
of the daughters of husbands her fiance
he's like one of the main cast members
on Roseanne okay yeah that's why I saw
that shells like oh [ __ ] I like that guy
on Roseanne and just to be clear I'm not
better than Big Bang Theory oh yes you
are
I just not think it's funny you are not
just a personal preference you are way
better than this do
was deported to Russia and like I said
he was charged with attempted murder a
baby get in trouble because everyone's
like bro we understand bro there's like
a Victor's parade that yeah but he said
he's going to jail because he didn't
actually kill him he's like I call from
that I've often called to court you are
[ __ ] because he actually lived huh go
to jail now he did admit to the stabbing
but that he didn't mean to kill him
it was joke stabbing you universe that
anybody just because I missed the heart
on purpose yes your lawyer you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that's why you
are sentenced watching Big Bang Theory
for ten seasons
[Music]
[Music]